d'un côté de la frontière un avion
britannique atterri en ukraine avec à
son bord des cargaisons de missiles
antichars destiné à kiev de l'autre côté
de la frontière russie l'armée poursuit
son déploiement chaque partie se défend
de vouloir faire la guerre mais tout le
monde semble s'y préparer
les etats unis annoncent une nouvelle
aide militaire à l'ukraine de 200
millions de dollars qui s'ajoutent aux
450 millions déjà
si elle fut réellement ce qu'elle est
capable de faire avec les forces hamas à
la frontière ce sera un désastre pour la
russie huit ans après avoir un excellent
à crime et la russie refusent toujours
de retirer les dizaines de milliers de
soldats qu'elle a positionnés à la
frontière avec l'ukraine kiev et les
occidentaux accusent moscou de vouloir à
nouveau envahir l'ukraine et de soutenir
les rebelles pro russe de l'est
ukrainien en guerre contre le pouvoir
central une accusation que les
séparatistes récuse
le cren essaye depuis très longtemps de
prouver au monde entier qu'elle est dans
une sorte d'état de guerre avec la
fédération de russie et que la russie
est une partie au conflit en doute les
déclarations que l'on entend sont basés
sur ciment moscou exige toujours un
accord écrit des occidentaux qui stipule
que l'ukraine ne rejoindra jamais l'otan
et qui réclame le retrait de l'alliance
atlantique des pays baltes pour moscou
ces demandes sont non négociables et
pour les états unis elles sont
inacceptables
alors que la rencontre de vendredi entre
anthony blinken et son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov approche le fossé entre
les deux parties se creuse